hello and welcome to this video playing
cm henry onyekuro
ko guru let's see
get some
ready with e3
yeah that's a bit of an odd line um that
i actually have
faced a couple of times already
looks um strange to me but
i'm not quite certain how to if there is
a refutation
so what i'm trying to say it's a little
bit like a rogozin but there is no pin
which makes the whole thing a bit bit
weird
with d4 that would be at least oops a
pin
okay um knight to c6 i can also just
take here
and allow this
okay so i take here
bishop a3
um i don't know bishop a3 is actually
debatable if this is doing all that much
i mean rookie 8 is probably a useful
move anyway and i can simply take the
pawn
so black simply blunted a pawn away for
more or less nothing
i don't think the tempi are so relevant
in this position
he's just not attacking anything
okay um
queen takes there was bishop b5
i have to be have to be alert this is
just the typical kind of game that i
lose because
with all honesty here i'm just being
totally frank if
if the opponent plays the opening in
such a terrible
way i always think okay that must be the
worst pets ever and they can never make
a move that is
remotely decent and
still they have a rating i mean no he
has to have some kind of ability
and then i overlook something because i
just don't pay attention anymore
i mean i have no clue how you could play
this this this bad in opening because
it's
just extremely obvious that that you
cannot play like that
and still they do it okay e4 you want to
lose more time
or what
but the thing is no people like that
they often are tactically
um alert and they sometimes
have this um advantage of not
understanding that they're actually
worse
and then they just play optimistic moves
and all of a sudden oh i'm winning
and this is happening so often you have
to really
um always pay attention even if the game
up to this point suggested like this i
can take this with check
dt i don't know
um
yeah i can take this with check it's not
clear that i should actually
just dropping back us probably
i could take on e4 maybe but that can
never work really
it is just it's really important to to
realize and i'm still have problems with
that after all those years
that even if you if your opponent has
a very limited like chess
knowledge and chess culture they can
still play well
in the sense of finding good moves you
don't need to
know stuff to find good moves you can
just find them
skill and knowledge are two different
things
okay after this speech let's have a look
here i should really win this position
it looks
extremely bad for black maybe um
just here queen trade
should be more or less
end of game
i could have taken with check i know but
it wouldn't be all that helpful
actually as b3 at the end would hang as
well
on this oops come on
rook a6
yeah okay so
now there are some things that i mean
just like bishop before
can never be a good move i mean it's
probably not it's not
a huge mistake but conceptually this
just makes no sense
really because it doesn't pin anything
this is
one thing it doesn't pin anything and
yes there are openings like for example
black can play
this but here your center is completely
flexible
or you can sometimes take without any
immediate structural benefit
but then you have this flexibility in
the center here after d5
you basically never want to take because
in such a situation
you won't you don't want to have d5
played so that
the double pawn that i get can be
immediately
um corrected so this is a
version of bishop before that that makes
really very little
sense so queen a4 check i'm not sure if
this is best though knight c695
is a direct way to play it it's maybe
not even the best
um a5 is an interesting
suggestion and
yeah so this is interesting because i
cannot
take twice here this this queen is
getting trapped um
but he took it and then just
gave up the pawn which yeah i don't
think
he's got enough compensation for
so take bishop here queen a6
now the thing is that the
position that i have has does not have
any weaknesses so
it's not much that he can attack sea
takes
was maybe even even better
but again i don't really see um
any reasonable compensation
castles queen e8 f3
and he just doesn't have anything to
attack so it was okay
knight d5 was odd because i just get
this additional tempo
yeah f6 i can take it but i wasn't
completely sure
because he has this maybe
let's say if i go here he can take on e4
and i felt i don't need those
complications
yeah and here this should be eight
yeah here i can take on e6 but this is
actually not so good
bishop f7 i have to take and at the end
this is dropping while this is a
huge advantage
yeah and tm loses the a7 pawn even
so this this opening concept i don't
think
is particularly good bishop before
it's not a losing move or anything like
that but it just doesn't quite
add up from a conceptual point of view
okay guys thanks for watching